welcome everybody to another episode of
the H Street podcast live if you're on
twitch if you're on YouTube it's not
live this has been pre-recorded in
previous day if you want to watch your
life to get on over to twitch.tv forward
slash is redirected you can watch the
live next time but not this time
because it's a recording like a song and
dance with the Cape yeah that's funny
you should do that for next time
today's episode is sponsored by quip
audible and MVM T movement thank you to
them
today's guest is the great and wonderful
pioneer of YouTube hardly Morenstein
that's got to be one of the most Jewish
names I've ever heard props to him
Harley Morenstein he's got he's like a
he's like a Jewish warrior like when you
like he's a big guy and he's got like a
big beard and [ __ ] and like because when
you think about a Jew you usually think
about like like a guy who looks like me
you know like a doe a little boy but
they're what had to be Jewish warriors
cuz you think back to the biblical
stories of like King King George what
was the guy's name that's a restaurant
what's this guy's name the old Jewish
King he was a warrior the old King David
yeah so King David was apparently
kicking ass back in the day so you know
that there's some warrior blood in the
Jewish line it's not a meat but it isn't
some and he happens to be a warrior Jew
is what I mean to say he seems really
don't know warrior vibe yeah there's
like like an Israel there's like a yeah
my name is Mort steed but then there's
like warriors in Israel you have
everything right it's American I guess
it's really American like in Israel I
wasn't thinking what is the the Jewish
stereotype like inside Israel you have
different stereotypes right right right
right here I've learned there's so much
like more going on the American Jew is
like oh I need to call the electrician
to pull to put in this light bulb what
are the stereotypes in Israel it's I
don't know there's like really dumb ones
but it's more like depending on like
Ashkenazi or Safari
so you guys who don't know Ashkenazi is
European Jew Sephardic is Middle Eastern
Jew like near Arabic almost kind of like
how you have here and I don't know
what's politically correct here by like
how there's like like black people will
have shut it down at times that black
people shut it down
there's theory there some white people
right sorry white people have got their
wall like this cuz their asses be so
high that's one of my favorite ones from
Eddie Murphy good sorry whatever so what
but I'm actually really curious about
what are the stereotypes about Sephardic
and Ashkenazi Jews I don't worry all
right are not as good with cooking or
like they won't make enough that's true
that's not a ton of food there's no such
thing as like running out of food right
and I skin eyes is like don't put like
don't comment on many people they're
cheaper is that part of it because I
feel like that's real yeah what else you
got mMmmm that can't be the only one
like it's interesting I think
everybody's friend is the other night
okay but there's like a stereotype that
there too so I love that even amongst
the Jews in Israel there's one sect
that's really - it's like all gays are
cheap but the Yemenites they're super
cheap watch out for those guys it's it's
just it's it's fascinating to think that
like everybody thinks about Jews in this
way but then when you go to Israel when
everyone's Jewish you have all these sub
stereotypes it just kind of shows how
stupid it all is
it is really dumb and like no one our
age really talks about this stuff
anymore it's like all this stuff is
there any other interesting ones because
I think it's great well what do you what
do people think about the the that the
Sephardic Jews a lot of times they go
together with like the obviously minify
time explain what our skin is our seam
is like a jersey Shore's a Jew
it's like a a what
going on I got my pop collar forget
about it I just got herpes the other day
forget I just do Lola rubbing alcohol I
got my dick and another girl forget
about it
eight but on the muse Rock a and they
dance they said I guarantee nobody's
upset about making fun of our soon a
okay anyway
that was a nice little any other
stereotypes that we can talk about here
any other people we can piss off I am
super excited about this weekend we are
going tomorrow hopefully
with with post to Coachella backstage
hopefully like we just before coming
here you asked if we want to come he's
like I got tickets for you guys the
thing with post is that like whenever he
invites you somewhere you know you're
gonna be on a crazy reckless almost
helpless journey because like he'll get
you there and because his life is so
insane and he's playing tomorrow at
Coachella yeah so it's almost like I'll
get you in but beyond that you're in a
war you you mean your own it's like hey
man nice to see I love you buddy thanks
for all you're the best and then he goes
out in there and then it's just mean yo
like you know just like it's floating in
space it's exciting it's fun it's a
thrill right
I'm really excited never been to
Coachella no I hope I don't know what to
expect what what what I imagine is that
well there's like I guess there's two
portions there's like the public area
and then there's like the backstage yeah
the artist area that'd be cool I'm gonna
harass I'm gonna harass people like I'm
gonna be that guy who's taking pictures
with all the famous people who shouldn't
be there yeah I mean hey Drake Drake hey
Ben
here's my let's play for tonight here's
my here's my card I'm gonna bring cards
here's my card it just has my Twitter
tag oh my god it's a USB key oh wow data
get him
they never see
and then on it is the spyware is blow
over and it stalls the h3 app which is
unloads a [ __ ] virus to the whole
network and then on Monday we're going
with the whole clan the h3 clan and the
Teddy fresh clan there's eight of us to
Disney delay it's a company event we're
gonna build memories that will Latin
door beyond these more these mortal
bonds I guarantee I don't know we're
just it's gonna be the best time
nobody's ever gonna forget about it
we're going it's gonna be adorable we're
gonna all wear matching outfits and
shirt we have to do the shirts yeah so
if you happen to be on Disney Land on
Monday and you see a big group of
hooligans walking around and red beanies
come say hi it'll be fun so there's a
couple things I won't talk about before
we bring Harley and end on that first
things first the h3 live show that we
had planned for the 26th yes what Brad
buried we pulled the effing plug on that
B and it was so I don't want to I don't
want to throw any blame around okay but
here's what happened we were I don't
know how to say this without a lot of
misunderstanding in the process of the
prices on the tickets right so and and
and somebody somebody put the tickets up
without finalizing the details with us
first of all we were misled about the
price like we were told there was going
to be $3 in services fees so the ticket
is 30 bucks I kind of wanted to do them
for 25 but then they threw it up for 30
without consulting so then I was like
okay fine so 33 was what I thought would
be the final price out the door but what
happened when ended up happening was
there were so many fees so much taxes
and [ __ ] it ended up going from 30 to 50
bucks so two people coming into our live
show would end up paying
a hundred dollars to come watch us do
the podcast that was a good podcast I
wasn't comfortable with that at all I
mean our last show at The Improv was
twenty two bucks and like I don't know
if there was like a couple bucks service
charge but it wasn't but that was it
it wasn't 50% of the ticket price and so
one the tickets went up without us
knowing and the price was cut a little
higher than I wanted and then two we
didn't realize that first all the fees
that came with it than what I after
people complain to us yeah okay what the
hell that was just three bucks I thought
it would cost thirty three bucks plus
tax and so then I saw that there was
these insane fees and I was just so
pissed off and I yelled at them and I
was like dude this this isn't right this
isn't the way it's supposed to be so
they go back to the venue and then the
venue magically reduces the the
convenience fee from 1050 down to like
three bucks and then I was like okay can
you refund everyone who already bought
tickets like well I don't know we're
dealing with the AXS and there and I'm
like dude and it just said and I was
just angry I was like why didn't you
reduce the price from three dollars out
the get-go like what what what the hell
they says well nobody asked us to I was
like okay the whole thing was just super
sour and and it just didn't feel right
anymore and we weren't sure if people
were going to get refunded who bought
before and after most of all we really
didn't that wasn't the price we wanted
for this kind of show it's made us
uncomfortable that people would pay so
much and and also a lot of people have
to travel so right you'd pay for
traveling food drinks and and a hundred
bucks for tickets it's like twenty bucks
for parking no penalty so we're just
like you know what this isn't right
let's just let's just pull the plug on
this so everybody who bought tickets is
getting a full refund including all the
convenience fees and everything and I
know on Twitter a couple of good were
like well I bought plane tickets and so
I did genuinely feel bad about that so
what I offered on Twitter and if
anybody's listening bought tickets in it
airplane
it emailed a net HTH reproductions calm
and we will help compensate you
personally on on that there is one funny
anecdote the guy on twitter is like man
i got [ __ ] by this i bought plane
tickets i was like alright well you know
will compensate you thinking that what
how much is a domestic flight like $200
he sends me the receipt two first-class
tickets 1600 bucks
i was like bro i don't even fly
first-class I can't I can't I can't pay
you $1600 bro both some life choices you
have to live with we haven't fully
looked into all the details yet because
we want to just get everything first all
the people that are to compensate and
look into the details and makes
decisions a bit we like when we opened
that one ready what Dan cannula yeah so
anyway if you if you got if you bought a
plane send your your proof of purchase
to Dan and well well that will help you
out how we can but hey that's crazy that
you fly here to see us you know
acknowledge how freaking crazy that is
thank you ma'am what else I mean I
wanted to talk there's a couple of
things I wanted to talk about here for
one this is kind of personal but I feel
like it's interesting alright I don't
know how to broach this but I feel like
I want to talk about it okay we've been
chopped okay we've been trying to get
pregnant we being me either's been
sticking her dick right my belly button
I know it does good when you say we it's
like well I'm trying to get a dealer
pregnant when we say we try but okay
whatever we're we've been trying to get
pregnant we don't really know how it
works
Neela's been I've been rubbing my dick
all over HeLa we're not really sure the
mechanics of how you Lisbon
we don't know how it works so we've been
trying but so far another things work
this is not what I agreed to talk about
okay so we've been trying and getting
you you think like by the population of
the world that getting pregnant would be
something easy was it like seven billion
mouth-breathers in this world it's taken
up all the oxygen you know and china
they have like laws they're like you can
only have one kid or we throw the second
in the river everyone's scared about
overpopulation i can't even get a have a
kid how did we get to this point in
history and evolution if it's this hard
to get a kid like we like you've been on
birth control for like two years and
recently in the past couple months
you've been doing like ovulation tests
timing it out and stuff wait what are
you saying I'm in off maybe that's the
problem
no we figured it out you went all
brokers or you doesn't go honk birth
control so we've been trying and trying
it's so and it's so disappointed because
you try it all month all month guys no I
don't know if I want to talk about this
we try all month and then it's it's just
it's disappointed because ela gets her
period and then you and then it's like
[ __ ] you have to wait another month and
it again it starts to get really
stressful at this point when you're
actually start trying but but what's
frustrates me is like what is going on
with this planet where everyone's just
getting out kids
but apparently a lot of people have this
problem a lot of our friends yeah almost
everyone that I know had really hard
time can it happen right I don't know
we had another friend who just had a kid
like a year ago they said they were
trying like with tests like timing it
out and stuff for six months and I'm
like where are all these people coming
from when you're 18 if you just buy it's
just like they make it sound like you
just touched a guy and you're seriously
and sex education that's what it makes
it sound like sperm can last for 30 days
so even if you have sex when she's on
her period thus warped this the sperm
can hide in her vagina for 30 days and
get her pregnant when she ovulates it's
like seriously
so my point my lesson to you is don't
use protection god it was most likely
you'll be fine I'm just kidding
protection is honestly to keep your dick
from rotting off your body no and to
prevent unwanted pregnancy let's not
start some rumors now that were use a
condom I guarantee it's worth it so I
don't know that's just something that's
that's I'm just trying I'm trying to be
more honest right I'm trying to be more
gentle I'm trying to talk about what's
on my mind a little bit this is
something that we've been thinking a lot
about and doing you know for a while so
let's talk about it let's be real again
have a [ __ ] I'm trying to I'm trying
maybe I'm maybe yeah maybe we're doing
something wrong maybe it's supposed to
go somewhere else no okay I don't know
you know Einstein says that the
definition of insanity is trying
something over and over again and not
getting resolved gotta stick it
somewhere else yellow I don't mean like
the but I was just making a joke I just
making joke I just wanted people to know
that was an anal sex joke or anything
all right what else we got here you guys
heard about all this I was gonna make a
joke about how I got in trouble got in
trouble for the transphobic tweet and
that's why the show was canceled but I
didn't add a border I don't really want
to talk about that I think it's whatever
there's a couple of videos I want to
watch but maybe we can watch it with
Harley cuz he's here
mm-hm cuz I've got that Count de aquila
video and the st. Claire news clip that
I wanted to watch maybe I should bring
Harley him
is that weird though did like do that
and then talk to him maybe we should
just watch it now it's not weird it's
not we're nowhere
alright apparently it's not we're deal
said let's do with them so let's go to a
quick commercial break we will be right
back with ya boy Harley we're gonna have
a lot of fun there's so much to discover
there's so much to learn in this life
it's gonna blow your mind don't go away
you guys hear that that's the sound of
everybody's favorite electric toothbrush
quip who's also incidentally the sponsor
of today's episode when it comes to your
health brushing your teeth is one of the
most important parts of your day and qyp
knows that they've combined dentistry
and design to make a better stronger
slicker more beautiful electric
toothbrush here's the deal
quip is the new electric toothbrush that
packs just the right amount of vibration
into a slimmer design at a fraction of
the cost of a bulkier traditional
electric toothbrush I mean this is it
this is all it is and that's all you
need you ever see one of these like oh
it's got a whole package it's like a
power tool
you have to like unholster it out of
your belt it's like give me a break this
is all you need
guiding pulses alert you when it's time
to switch sides making brushing the
right amount of time completely
effortless
I personally a lot of people I brush for
30 minutes because I'm neurotic but a
lot of people are like I don't know how
long I need a brush that's the genius
about quick it vibrates for thirty four
three minutes it tells you when to
switch sides
and and you know when you're done and
when when you've done enough brushing
that's when I use this I usually I'm
about to stop before really ups so like
normally I guess I would do two minutes
but then this makes me that's funny cuz
when it put when it tells me to stop I'm
like I just started you're in the same
by the way I thought I had a cavity and
I have had one cavity in my life when I
was like eight and the pain went away I
was like Eli have it yeah yeah there's
no way I think I have a cavity he was
like oh hell yeah I can't wait for Ethan
to go get [ __ ] up by the dentist and I
was like nah just not enough I'm happy
to say thanks to equip by the way it
comes with a mount that sucks right to
the mirror right there dude also because
that thing cleans your mouth should also
be clean wept subscription plan
refreshes your brush on a dentist
recommended schedule delivering new
brush heads every three months for just
five dollars including free shipping
worldwide which is
just I was free shipping worldwide who
what what kind of underground consortium
is this what kind of weird they took the
time to make a little package for a
little toothbrush refill
it's a pod because they didn't it do you
already have this quip is backed by a
network of over 10,000 dental
professionals including dentists
hygienists and dental students again the
dental students don't I don't I wouldn't
ask them for advice they're students
they don't know anything they're
students I'm not what am I supposed to
take the endorsement of a student oh
yeah you should really use this
toothbrush what do you do I'm studying
dentistry I'll talk to my dentist most
toothbrushes don't get named one of Time
Magazine's best inventions of the year
but guess who did quip find out why by
getting want yourself one of these
amazing toothbrushes quip starts for
just twenty-five bucks if you go to get
quip comm /h through right now you'll
get your first refill pack for read with
a quip electric toothbrush that's your
first refill pack free at get quick calm
slash h3 spelled GE t qu IP doubt cop /
h3 if you are not quipping yet then you
are quitting life I don't know but give
it a shot because I genuinely love this
product I think you will too so thank
you very much squid for sponsoring us up
next we've got everybody's most beloved
audio book service audible for our
audience audible is offering a free
audiobook with a 30-day free trial if
you want to listen audible has got it
just go to audible.com slash h3 podcast
or text h3 podcast - 500 - 500 500 500
and browse their unmatched selection of
audio content download a title free is
start listening it's that flippin easy
whether you want to feel healthier get
motivated learn something new or just
relax and listen audible has got a book
for that here's what I recommend to you
guys you've probably seen the last Jedi
it's been a lot of people had a lot of
opinions about this book okay I
personally thought it was okay does that
mean yeah I thought it was okay is that
okay
but he
I loved it oh you loved it all right
well great today's guests loved it too
Harley is apparently a super fan I don't
know if we're talking this is
prerecorded so I don't know where we are
on the farm I don't know where we are in
the conversation but maybe we're talking
about right now the last Jedi expanded
edition by Jason Frye is an audio book
that expands on the original story
because they cut a lot they I just got
to say a lot of the characters were
undeveloped a lot of the plotline were
undeveloped so in this story you got all
the details all the development you
really get a better sense of
understanding of what was going on so if
you didn't like it you get to know what
was going on if you loved it you get
even more I highly recommend listening
to the last Jedi expanded edition and
it's gonna be a lot of fun here was what
else you got speed control you can
listen to books faster or slower the
narration the speed suits your desires
that's really cool what did they have
them read it I like five different
speeds today's audio books about to you
babe yeah it's probably something where
they like pitch shifted it's AI so guys
get a free audiobook with a 30 day free
trial at audible.com slash h3 or text a
street podcast all one word to 500 500
that's audible.com slash h3 podcast or
text pod h3 podcast to 500 500 go listen
to the last jet expanded edition for
free that link by the way is audible.com
slash h3 podcast not h3 thanks
audible.com so I did about God mm-hmm
versus I can't talk you guys get the
idea
it's audible.com slash h3 podcast go
listen to the book for free the last
Jedi expanded edition Thank You audible
for supporting us
and finally we've got you know um you
love them and VMT movement these guys
are the greatest right they make the
best watches in the game you gave me
these are yours but now they're making
the best sunglasses in the game oh my
God look at this dude these actually
look and feel amazing well thank you man
they feel sturdy they look great I feel
like this is the best looking sunglasses
maybe I've ever worn
they really are yeah I've been trying to
find a pair like this for a long time
these guys listen here buddy
so here's the deal with sunglasses you
you you get a nice pair it costs 200
bucks or more or more my thing is when I
buy a nice pair of sunglasses I end up
like not liking it after a week I'm like
damn I didn't know like these I don't
know why that happens that happens to me
but so on the other side when you buy
like a $30 pair they just break and
they're crap and they're built like like
garbage
so here movement comes along they say
you know what's flip it how about we
make quality trendy sunglasses at a fair
price these things aren't cheap plastic
they're acetate meeting it's more
durable it's not plastic it's acetate
they specifically said to say that I
don't know if that means anything to you
but apparently it does acetate look it
up they start at just 70 bucks though
these girthy meaty acetate polarized
these things are slick and they start at
70 bucks if that's not a compromise of
style quality and price then call me the
pulp because I'm not lying okay
so they got they have a ton of styles to
choose from they got everything got
classic trendy round aviator mirrored
polarized for him for her for it you're
sure to find the perfect fair this pair
is called the renegade because that's
just kind of how I identify and wine is
called Savage found it see those the
savage I knew it all along
so guys movements already revolutionized
the watch industry now it's time to
change the game for sunglasses get
15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MDM t.com slash
h3 go to nvm t.com slash h3 and joined
the flippin movement today get 15% off
these excellent amazing sunglasses thank
you so much to our sponsors guys let's
get right back into it shall we
welcome back everybody they see podcast
what up we are back with Harley
Morenstein I'm on the show I was May I
was joking before first of all welcome
I'm so happy to have you I'm wonderful
yes yep I'm so happy you're here because
first of all let me just say that it's a
little surreal for me to be sitting here
with you I probably told you that
because we hung out a couple of times
but you were probably the first person
that I watched on YouTube before I even
dreamed about having a YouTube channel I
was at work and we would pass around
epicMealTime videos like amongst each
other in the office and that was just
you were like you know was just like you
were YouTube royalty I mean your YouTube
royalty and so it's really weird to have
come to the point where I can sit at a
table with you and do a podcast that
means a lot that means a lot sometimes I
don't know if I'm like I'm like I look
at the landscape of YouTube and I'm like
am I like Nick Cage of YouTube where
it's like yo this guy everyone knows
this guy everyone loves this guy this
guy's a legend he's been in there man
he's been there it's like what's the
last movie box office how to feel okay
okay but you know what he's gonna get
another chance we'll do another one he's
been that solid right or I'm like maybe
I'm like gene Simmons of YouTube it's
like this guy still here he looks like
now oh my god you're not genes man
you're different I'm a 'king me toos
between the two and they give and and
who wouldn't want to be in a cage no I
want to be someone's gotta be in a cage
somebody like that's me yeah I feel like
I'm the Nick Cage guy you know like I'm
like you got a job I'm on it right I'll
do it
come on the bacon guy will do it right I
think that was like a motto for a while
cause it's like you know I'll just tell
people that just so that I'm not all
about bacon I'll take roles in other
people's videos and they'd be like oh
that's awesome just come here and hold
this bacon in yeah
so it's like everything I'm doing
yelling bacon well the first thing I
noticed about you when I see you is that
the guy that I would used to watch back
then looked a lot different from the guy
that's sitting in front of me right now
you're you're you look good dude you got
you you look good you dress good thank
you you're killing it what's going on
what happened well here's so here's the
secret
I just watched myself look worse and
worse every single week and it's weird
to have that documented every week right
where you just like see your progression
or regression right and it's crazy cuz
it's kind of like this I feel like I've
been traveling a lot lately so if you
look I'm kind of like on the down I feel
terrible but I got gel in my hair so
that counters everything you feel good
with the gel I didn't interview the
other day like i legit did an interview
the other day and after the interviewer
was like are you single female a real
life drawing you that much longer a live
one was like are you saying that I was
who says can you imagine being
approached by a female like that I can't
very unusual
that's the Nic Cage [ __ ] I pollicis all
I thought you must know that I was in
the Ghost Rider movie equivalent of
YouTube so but you have a girlfriend so
that yeah she's outside yeah brought her
really entertaining shredder shredder is
actually under the desk
so why you come on my show and liable
why isn't he jumping in my face right
now he has zero and ten that's all I
have like what tell me more about like
your physical transformation because I'm
always someone who's unhappy with the
way I look even though I make it meme
out of it doesn't I'm not like utterly
depressed but I know I'd be happier if I
was more fit yeah you're like me in a
way that I at least of what I could
imagine is like how you know after I
just literally put up on my interest or
a picture of your belly
look at you looking down at the camera
with your belly there oh great like it's
like you posted yourself as well i
remember i i i have these times where
i'll sit down like to put on socks
oh look at this sad boy you know there's
a lot of people who can relate to that
right now yeah and whoever's around them
like yellow might come give there's a
pinch so I gotta want to some would come
touch it they're like it's fine it's not
even that lying to me you're lying
did this ever happened to you this was
one of my I was fatter than I am now my
most fat and I was like I gotta do
something others I went to tuck tie my
shoe and I couldn't breathe that was my
lowest point did that wrapping you well
I don't know if I can't breathe but like
I couldn't to put on the socks kind of
it would be like when I'm done I'd be
like right oh my god there's like a
parent wrapper there yeah yeah yeah
there I had to hold my breath I would
literally take him deep breath
that's inouye year age for me I had I
had a moment where I was just looking in
the mirror and I just had like an angle
before I was getting in the shower
probably charging a phone at the same
time and whatever and I just looked back
and I was like like is that my eyes for
my back no no or where does my back and
my ass begin I'm like what's happening
and I was like just like that's my body
as it gets like fully like people joke
like potato but like I was full-on
potato ass and that was just a moment
for me I was like oh I should maybe
change a bit mmm all I did was drop the
carbs they did the no carb thing Kate oh
yeah the keto diet it was good that's it
I enjoyed it where he's well on the keto
no III got off it I you know I think
it's not meant to be forever type thing
huh but a mere one of the guys that
cooks on Epic Meal Time has been on it
like non-stop but he's just gone from
like disgusting slob to really trim guy
and as before enough their picture yeah
they're wild and yeah it was literally
just for me a big thing was drinking
water because if you drink water then
you stop snacking and oh if you're
watching in your disgusting slob and I
I'm a disgusting slob but I transitioned
back and forth between the two i I I
would say drink and it's always sounds
cliche and dumb and you're like all you
idiot drink more water
seriously I started drinking if you aim
to drink like six to eight litres of
water a day don't even get me started on
Coco
khoka love that [ __ ] but it makes it
makes it it's it's like even without
breaking it down it makes you want to
eat more the fate that like it makes you
want to make sugar doesn't work no well
this is what I heard
apparently we have triggers to sweetness
and remember everything I'm saying is
nonsense who the [ __ ] are my arms very
one that ever should be commenting on
that stuff but what I think dead yeah
inspire quote me on this is that when
you have something sweet like diet coke
is super sweet coke Zero super sweet
there are receptors in our body where
it's like sweet means high-calorie it's
a tree so it's like Oh incoming intense
sweetness crank up the metabolism let's
go boys lots of sugar coming through oh
no sugar that's weird I thought there
was gonna be lots of sugar
I guess we're wrong and then it creates
these false alarms so the next time when
you are eating something sweet or
something that does have a lot of carbs
in it your body's like I is just joking
it's diet coke don't doesn't matter and
then you just get destroyed and I think
that's right yeah I feel I think that's
true I felt like that's gonna be right
the biggest thing though for me was
sleep because I'm like I hate sleeping I
love staying up late I'm always like I
don't need a sleep it's just stupid like
you're better off you know trying to
stay awake as hard as you can enjoy
sleeping I love sleeping when it
happened
but trying to sleep but now these days
it's like once midnight rolls around I'm
like oh now no one's gonna [ __ ] with my
[ __ ] I can start that video game I
wanted to start or I can go and I can
work on something that's like a side
thing or I did you know
sit sit there just smoking watching like
five hours of a cult on Netflix whatever
it is I just value that Solo time I get
there at night so how did you make that
sweat you're saying you used to do that
and now you sleep well I go now I've
been traveling so I go back and forth
all over time I've had a terrible sleep
last couple days but I noticed that me
aren't I my best it's like a domino
effect it starts with water and then
sleep and then I want to go to the gym
and then you just don't want to snack at
that point mmm because you're already
committed you don't want to do any sauce
when you went from potato in the mirror
yeah I don't know why I'm on my way back
you look good
a potato in the mirror right now yeah
you're not a hitter when they mirror my
eye which is the Jewish warrior we're
talking about how you fish for it before
but we said that you look like a warrior
thing there's two types of Jews in the
world there's like little like Al Oh
like me and then there's like Jewish
warriors like during the king of David
like biblical [ __ ] but anyway when you
went from potato in the mirror to Jewish
was it was it like a straight just like
you were like I'm in I'm going yeah it's
it's if you really think about all the
times I look to myself when I was
terrible
like all those times culminate in many
false starts right there's so many times
worse like now it's the time doesn't fly
and then something happens like wait
tomorrow my sight I know because that's
good exactly yeah but those false starts
are important they really are I really
feel like you build on that leg like I
maybe got to a place where I felt
comfortable because I had all those
false starts leading up to it that
wouldn't have happened if I didn't feel
one way you know many times you know cuz
after the fifth time we're gonna be am I
gonna say this is going down again or am
I gonna lie to myself and man how many
times for me it was like 27 times I like
doing to keep failing like that no I
think that's important for people
listening to remember that it's okay to
have those false starts because
eventually you're gonna get to the point
you won't be at yeah definitely well
that's why I think it's happy what's
happening you know when you when you do
you guys ever catch [ __ ] for wasting
food on Epic Meal Time like I'm sure
that's probably the biggest criticism
people say about the show yeah there's
lots of there's lots of criticisms one
that's consistent that comes up is do
you guys eat all this and it's like it's
a multi-tiered question answer there are
times where we've food has been
contaminated and we've thrown out an
uncomfortable amount of food where we've
been like Oh somebody we're like that's
time we do we're like that sucks you
know we're like visible otherwise but
it's just you know that sometimes other
times we're like we're five guys on
camera and there's about eight people
off camera okay and people on set like
aren't ready they're like you're there
like filming for six hours they're ready
like they want to eat it people want to
try it you know we
they were episodes where we knew there
was gonna be a big waste like one time
we put we stuffed 50 Birds into ten pigs
and attached all the pigs at mouth we
did it years ago and I just knew that it
wasn't going to get eaten and we
literally ate like two of the pigs and
the other eight we have set it up with a
soup kitchen in advance they came with
like garbage bags literally scooped at
all hours I was like what's it gonna be
and they were like soup for a year well
so I was like okay yeah it's cool we did
it we did our TV show we did we did
donated a portion of the budget to
feeding America org right but a lot of
people are like you know once you give
that to like homeless people on the
streets and it's like you actually can't
yeah it's illegal yeah like it's it's
like you just expose yourself if you're
not if you're like a production come out
of letting a liability
yeah it doesn't mean you could feed
people you can't feed someone if someone
gets sick like you haven't sure that
you're screwed for that some guys just
gonna be like I puked and so I'm suing
you for poison well yeah America this is
even even like if you go look at grocery
stores we're like a lot of times when
we're doing meat heavy episodes
we're buying meat that's getting that's
gonna be expired anyways we go there
whenever there's stuff on sale like
expired meats it's like one more day we
go when we buy all those up those get
thrown out a lot of the stuff that we
use would have gotten thrown out and you
know if you ever watched the grocery
store what they'll do is they'll like
triple quadruple bag things and lock the
dumpster in the back cuz they could
throw something out and someone can go
in the dumpster eat it get sick and then
also sue
god bless so yeah I actually really do
love America god bless I am Canadian and
I really love this place every time I
come here I'm like I love this country
here when yeah or I lived in Montreal
yeah you're back and can I lived here
for two years and now I'm back in Canada
and I come here for work very often
mm-hmm
who do you guys film from now Toronto so
can you can you get rid of the food
there is it's not as sooo happy there
right no you it's still the same
scenario like you uh like you couldn't
get in trouble because we're we are a
company so you can't be giving food and
don't want any liability exactly you
can't feed someone you could you know
you can get in a lot of [ __ ]
for that you know what I mean if someone
starts barfing they go to the hospital
and like [ __ ] goes down and it's really
expensive like that's that's on us you
know I don't really understand that
criticism though as if flex somehow this
one large meal you made is gonna solve
world hunger well the biggest thing is
like I noticed the people are always
like oh look at that waist and you know
what everyone wastes yeah but before
epic before Epic Meal Time happened I
never did anything I didn't do anything
like for the homeless or anything like
that and episodes where we've gone to
soup kitchens and volunteer and and
stuff like that or if we donated the
most I've done is during this time on
Epic Meal Time like it kind of like the
guilt aspect of it because there was
some inspired me to do something but
then the people that go in common
they're like oh wow look at this guy I'm
like [ __ ] I hope you volunteer
right I hope you're a volatile year over
here right now talking [ __ ] about this
but if you're just some [ __ ] that's
you know like oh man look at this guy
wasting food and it's a bull you're on
you're on the internet let your mouth
throw in like half eaten Carl jr. burger
cigar meal they never finished our
Carlos you know you know that yeah and
also I feel like I feel like at the same
time it's like you know if you were too
overly scrutinize so many things you
really can't a Quebec well look at you
paying for Internet when people are
starving yeah and you can feed children
for a year we live in America it's the
most opulent is that the right word
opulent most / abundantly resource
country that's ever existed I don't even
think it's just it's like the way it's
it's messed up because as you were
saying grocery stores are even throwing
out their [ __ ] like whatever you guys
are doing for entertainment purposes in
the problem when grocery stores and
restaurants are throwing out every ounce
of food well what I heard is that and
you know there's something I heard is
that we have enough food on the planet
yeah feed the planet right it's just a
logistics issue right like if we can
somehow move the corn in this country
around the world at you know basically
the thing that we need to solve world
hunger is teleporters we're at we'll
figure out teleportation we can teleport
under all the corn to Africa things are
good as I understand it
it's that simple you guys God there be
so many weird like things happening with
tell apportion exist teleportation the
clock no I'm not gonna go there I better
not keep my mouth shut
why why do things happen when you make
jokes no it's just embarrassing not that
I'm gonna get charged more why did you
get in trouble no no I'm okay okay I've
embarrassed myself several times on this
podcast I think that's the one thing
when people become creators that they
don't understand or they'll never really
grasp is you got to do it you got to go
all into it you got to have fun you know
you got to for lack of a better example
pull your pants up really high and take
pictures of your gut like you've got to
be all out there everything and it stays
there right so like you can look like
you could ask any critter like I I was a
Viner also vine was like a big thing for
me for a period of year and a half like
you go back and if you had a vine
account like if you did trust me like it
was like ela e to anyone the content
that you have to be comfortable leaving
behind the trail of it right is everyone
will get embarrassed everyone will get
in trouble everyone will do some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] and if you ever get big enough
they'll go back I don't whine some
things he did in the past and make a
make an issue out of it and I just went
I looked at my my vine as an example and
I was like I'm an unfunny piece of [ __ ]
I'm like deleting every single vine I
was like can't believe I did this the
format of vine it was brutal and there's
a similar way of YouTube but that it's
just it requires you to be so fast-paced
you got to make content you got to slime
it out you can't ever think or work
about on it too long yeah on the podcast
it's like I sit here and I talk for for
hours and hours and hours and of course
I'm gonna say and do some stupid [ __ ]
it's just inevitable it's like I can't
even try to avoid it I just have to
embrace that I'm embarrassing the
biggest thing and I think we've learned
that even with like you know things in
the and in the recent past and stuff
with creators is everyone's gonna [ __ ]
up it's just how you handle it after the
fact that's the most important part
because I feel like what this society
loves American society Liz loves
building someone up on a pedestal yeah
and make it a big deal of them but then
we love knocking them off the pedestal
yeah and like clowning them but then we
also really love a comeback introduction
which is right like this guy's such a
good singer oh my God look at her face
that's terrible but he's a good singer
again you know when it's like kind of
like it's torturous to be in that
position it's hard to understand how
anyway you know what whatever let me ask
you this so when you guys were making it
I sometimes I go down the rabbit hole
you know what let's not talk about this
let's just [ __ ] go tomorrow let's go
take us there were there ever actual
medical concerns that you guys had
during the filming like I think back to
man verse food you know the story of
that show yeah he was eating the
gnarliest [ __ ] for so long the doctors
were like you're gonna die if you keep
doing this yep was it ever I mean I know
you were a potato in a mirror but I just
love that phrase thank you the good cuff
like I need you guys to write the
foreword now no there was never any
major food concerns and I mean if I can
go deep on some theories for a second
you know and I actually I met Adam
Richman a few times I never spoke about
about that specifically or anything like
that but this is just my theory is once
you've done three seasons of a show you
control a lot more if you are the talent
on the show so you kind of get like you
can get like kind of stepped on in your
deal the first three seasons but then
like you know once you get to that point
it's like now it is I who can make
demands right and you can make those
demands and I just feel if I had done
three seasons of that show I'd be like
hey you know what I'm tired of getting
really fat right and I want to start
paying for my trainer and in fact this
in between this season and last season I
did start to make a better difference on
my body and I want to host other shows
where you know they want maybe a trimmer
look so
other people eat now that's just it
yeah I'm like well what are we gonna do
well you could just say that I was gonna
die that's it like that I would die you
think that that's overhyped I I think if
I were him I would I would have done
that I would have been like kay we're
done now with this we're done like let's
be honest do I really have to to die for
people to it the answer is yes then yeah
it is saying you have to die I want to
watch you specifically you you I yes you
I've enjoyed your content I think you're
a great guy Adam eat you I want nothing
more than for you to slowly I want
boiling and on and on your funeral
I want to deep fry that confident and
forced you to take a bite of it oh
that's actually an actually never knew I
want to fill his coffin with ground beef
and nacho cheese coffin guaranteed
50,000 views and then out of Adam
Richmond's inside oh that's the mill I
want the service to be called potato and
the grave in dug grave yeah you know the
craters the crater saw are you going to
put in the gravy potato in the gravy no
yeah that's my life I can have you guys
on a Halloween episode now next year
potato the spookiest yeah it was like
you gave you don't like this episode you
gotta go listen to this podcast months
ago the shredder has this uncanny
ability to always find the most
uncomfortable place to say he's
literally right where I would put my
feet and I don't notice it he does this
tequila every more not every morning all
night he started doing this thing where
he'll he'll I will go to bed and then
he'll jump up on the bed and go right
next to her pillow like next to her face
and then somehow in the middle of the
night I wake up and I'm completely like
in the middle no no longer have my
Saturdays like sideways on my side
it just takes it over every night now
killer yeah now what she was less keyed
so he's so good that it's hard to
complain but I wanna literally I want to
strum through the window he's so good I
was just I was wondering what is it we
were talking about it briefly that
what is that impulse that one cute when
you want to kill cute things mm-hmm you
want to like squeeze them till they die
you're like oh you should die what is
that we are they just a weird thing I
don't know you my lover you're so
adorable and so defenses and so sweet I
want to kill you I'll kill you
is it like something like I could kill
you because I'm so much more powerful
than you are you're you are nothing and
I can't but you can see everyone goes it
right yeah like you can see and ant
would say to baby I want to squeeze him
right like everyone would say that they
won't say I want to kill you but no but
that destroys it until it's completely
obliterated cute Oh somebody said in he
said it's cute aggression yeah
can you get me a Wikipedia on the cute
aggression chameleon I exercise I
Gretchen unexplained like I'm five went
up at one point no it's just like all
interesting but it wasn't one of those
point four I named click it I was like
I'm in a gif mood so I didn't click it
but now like well actually this is
playful aggression not cute okay a
superficial aggressive behavior
superficial speak for yourself human
baby or young animal people grit their
teeth clenched their fists or feel the
urge to pinch and squeeze something they
considered cute well not actually cause
you're intending to playful aggression
is a type of dysmorphic display in which
a positive experience elicits
expressions usually associated with
negative emotion
there's behavior occurs more calmly
individuals who experience what is de
morphus emotions across a range of
society go down a hole that you clicked
amorphous this article sucks I was kind
of hoping for an explanation they're
just like yeah and you want to kill cute
things we all know about it
it exists um last year we were both that
creator summit YouTube Illuminati
anchored meeting yeah exactly are you
going this year no are you no no did you
get invited yes oh I was not invited I
think it might be because I shouted at
everyone I was gonna ask you last year
we were there and that was right after
like the whole and buckle in popular as
soon as as soon as
the six companies like pulled their ads
because they found that their ads were
playing in front of like weird YouTube
videos that they didn't they weren't
happy about I don't remember what it was
we were screaming about I remember very
clearly what did you know communication
this information yeah that's that was my
fault point but my main question was
like like I said I used to make vines
and vine ended vine was an app and it
ended I saw people like people existed
that you know were like you know what it
felt like when you were on the rise
you're like hey he'll I think it's gonna
be all right this YouTube thing it's
starting to come through now you know
like you had that feeling and it's like
whoa let's buy a better camera or a
laptop there's an investment aspect
there where you're gonna double down on
this career but there were people I'm
sure on vine that were like wow I just
got 150,000 followers I'm gonna move to
Los Angeles and they book the plane quit
their job and then they heard vine was
dead that must have happened surely and
we didn't hear about these stories
because obviously no one gives a [ __ ]
about vine or the people who use it so
what happened was I felt that YouTube
like is no different from vine in many
respects in the sense that it's like you
know we put all our eggs in the YouTube
basket and we hope that YouTube will
work out and that if you have a career
you have a career and that's great but I
just found out that these companies can
just close like they could be like
whoopsies ha ha we're not doing this
anymore so my question was to YouTube if
one company can complain about one
instance of a bad ad being on a bad
video that 6 it was the number was 6 I
believe 6 companies can pull away and it
affects all money making across the
entire site I needed to know how many
companies control the fate of YouTube
what if 8 companies backed out do we
close YouTube what if 10 back up do we
close YouTube and since we're in a room
of 200 people that dedicate their time
and their money and their effort to
making a life on YouTube which YouTube
capitalizes on as well we should know if
it's like hey guys things are much more
fragile than you think right and and we
got that I already found out how fragile
it was it was as fragile as Pepsi can be
like that sucks
that add going on that video so we're
pulling money off all of YouTube and so
are these other companies in YouTube's
like wait wait we totally agree we
totally agree the problem was how about
it the problem was how submissive they
were to these advertisers yeah it's it's
all you're talking about influencer
yeah and in an influence like scenario
you have infinite influence or ammo in
this room just this room let alone
everyone else right no it's people like
PewDiePie weren't even in that room but
like who still is a guy that lives and
breathes Oh YouTube yeah and and my
positioning was how many companies back
out until this whole thing shuts down
and they're like well then it was just
this one scenario and this is what would
bother me was Robert had said he was
like you know hardly put yourself in the
shoes of the Pepsi executive that had to
go and explain and I jumped in and I
don't know what this point was gonna be
but I was like I'm sorry I apologize but
we only have one time where we get you
guys face-to-face and I would love to
say hey I love you too thanks so much
for changing my life for the better
by the way they ran off stage right
after that till yeah yeah well the whole
point is like and I've been through
these things before they're it's so cool
they show us a great time but really if
you look at it you just need to see that
we go to this you know sooo secret
YouTube awesome meeting we get there
they have this face-to-face and he was
like well imagine the Pepsi executive
that had to explain to his superior my
uncle a [ __ ] [ __ ] about that guy yeah
that guy makes six figures there are
people in this room with popular
channels that will not make six figures
because they invest back into their
channel and maybe someone spent fifteen
thousand dollars that week on their
biggest video of the year and there was
no ads and no one told them but people
are YouTube's knew that that was gonna
happen and this Pepsi exec or whoever
knew that that was gonna happen
but we didn't know we didn't get the
heads-up and you know what Epic Meal
Time was never affected by the ad
pocalypse buzzing the reason why I think
YouTube
[ __ ] up is because I made more money
on Facebook last month see real-time
that I did on YouTube
Wow and that's pro monetization we'll
have to talk they won't even [ __ ] get
they won't even throw me a bone
not that I care I don't even upload our
videos but do you how many views do you
get let's see that I have like some like
we have like one video we put up and it
was like you know a recut of an older
video and it got over 30 million views
you know great yeah it is you know what
Facebook for example would really go
viral I can see that yeah yeah so what
was like we take our old content we take
content that exists we take out all of
our faces we take out the voice we take
out any context that would have timed it
and we make it just becomes like the
most epic lasagna instead of it starting
off with me at the fast-food being like
what like do a little bit it's like you
know cut out literally every single
person that's so you put me cut it and
you got a regear sometimes we put it in
square feet were like who made this and
put emojis and like literally throw a
plant out there yeah we play the game
you know what I never played the YouTube
game I never got into playing the
YouTube I feel like the game didn't even
exist when you guys were at your peak
but the game kind of came around YouTube
a hundred percent it did dude there was
no game then the biggest it was with
pretty long actually did the biggest
game then was just like there were
categories so it was like they would say
like food and like one video was shown
that day on food Tom comedy
entertainment movies and like if another
youtuber uploaded in food they say girl
what the [ __ ] bro you're my category
dude I thought you know like if you're
like if Tim Billy gato uploaded in food
I'm like that's weird brought on how you
feel if I started uploading an
entertainment right then what what I
don't want to choose weekend warriors
showing up at your crib I'll be throwing
down a King David there sounds a lot
better than potato in the mirror I feel
like Jewish warriors is a lawyer a
Jewish lawyer Jewish warriors just a
lawyer
but I was annoyed and to that point
about the
Illuminati secret meaning thing like if
you look at it I love you too I really
do and I'll probably always have if
YouTube is existing I will upload to
YouTube but there's a [ __ ] up when there
are articles out there being like this
guy makes five hundred thousand dollars
every month playing video games online
on a service called twitch
yeah you know that's a YouTube [ __ ] up
because you could make you could do
bigger than that on YouTube mm-hmm and
the millisecond people do they exist but
no one wants to talk about youtube as
much it's not exciting news it's like
you know what I mean it's like we just
we bash YouTube you know we don't yeah
exactly yeah I know it's even in like
the mainstream media that's what I
noticed like if you're talking about
twitch and how much money people make on
twitch it's like that must be like a
YouTube [ __ ] because they should be
mentioning it on YouTube but they don't
that's interesting in itself that
management the company has become so
unsexy they're just a bunch of [ __ ]
the people whatever I'm bitched about
YouTube so much but you're right you
make sure the point they're missing see
why didn't Drake stream for tonight on
YouTube that's a big deal yeah you know
and it by the way we're on twitch right
now if well yeah that's right if we were
on our podcast channel streaming the
numbers would be way higher mm-hmm but
it's better on twitch god it just feels
better the experience is better the
audience are more engaged the twitch
audience community I cuz I made a twitch
channel as well and I noticed that which
is a different audience yeah and you
know what like we put our Facebook
videos up Facebook is its own audience
yeah you big like Facebook Facebook can
like look is its own planet a hundred
percent make a million percent Facebook
is like our content doesn't have to
Rieger like they do were you like write
our content makes sense yes and no you
just cut out everything I would keep it
the boat I would keep it exactly as a or
literally you just take your video it's
basically a 10-second video of you with
like 100 beanies on it's like look how
many hats how open you know why to make
Joey salads God bust his soul was like
I'm killing it on Facebook yeah and
YouTube won't even
hey for me I don't know he doesn't make
it he's just getting D Montes every time
well as he should another lesbian
couples
mix mix child and broke a trump card
Facebook the thing about Facebook is
like if you look at it this way is the
biggest youtuber has like 63 million
subscribers right yes it's a huge deal
like the number one like like like that
I could think of just in the food space
just in food is like tasty and they have
96 million likes on Facebook it's really
and then you go look at some sports
teams that have like or soccer players
that have like a hundred something
million and if they upload and it's a
video native to Facebook Facebook's like
oh yeah we love video content we want to
be video players in the video game so
let's push that push that video push
that video like I have a friend who put
up a video one video it got 180 million
views and then he got 500 thousand likes
on his Facebook page first video one
time within a week YouTube has not in
forever done that to a channel or
someone or anything but that really yeah
the biggest thing is like let's say you
started a channel and I started a
channel we did it on Facebook the
biggest thing is we could share each
other's Channel right I remember when I
was negotiating the peace between Joey
and soffel they're initiating so Flo
didn't show it Cheryl shares and he
never paid up
yeah he did a night got a nice
everybody's like you know what it's fine
I think Facebook's still the Wild West I
feel like they're gonna start
something's got to happen there cuz it's
just too insane what's going on there
but my page is dead because they just
favor a video content so much like short
form snappy video content with like
crying laughing emojis everywhere yeah
that are like if you post a picture or
status update or anything it's like a
link any people saw this yeah I think
what would do very well is highlights of
the podcast with huh with interest it's
this is the most important part
subtitles woah that's a really good idea
8 damn job titles if you have the
subtitles it changes Facebook here's
thing you go on Facebook and it's just
three seconds counters of you and they
don't have to have the sound running
which is dirty so 100 million views yeah
it's like 179 million people that
scrolled by just didn't scroll by fast
enough and it plays without sound and if
you have subtitles people do again some
people allow you to watch during class
they're in clouds you got tips yeah I
knew you were gonna come in here with me
write that down
everybody I want ten I want ten
highlights on our channel we need
someone we need someone we optioning
that [ __ ] and we go for uploads a day I
have a disgusting feeling that if we
start posting those it's gonna be it's
gonna be sick you're gonna post in your
make a hole look at this now our lives
if but I don't have known your facebook
lives and I do hookup monetization I can
try I can connect you to a person I've
done that with two of my friends okay
yep yeah hook me up yeah I don't know if
they got monetized but I hooked them up
with the person okay that's it yeah what
do you got speaking of potato in the
mirror what do you got there my pizza
and a bag this is pizza and a bag it's
my jerky I have a jerky so okay good I'm
a really tell ya well it's so crazy
because I made let us hold it here hey
guys look he's available in Walmart
I like people just like killed you ever
expect Epic Meal Time man to do all this
and be like you know I'm always like no
I was joking like I literally made a
video where I was joking around mm-hmm
and it got views and I'm like oh let's
talk again next week we're joking man I
can't believe we're still joking I mean
it's like six years later I'm like yo
this jokes really heavy almost seven
years later I'm like I have I have found
the reasons internally within myself why
this joke will always be funny to me
and why I should value this joke and
I'll continue to joke with this joke
forever and I got to that place and I'm
like where can we take this joke snack I
love Walmart that's a joke it's sunny
it's called super snack time good Epic
Meal Time let me let me break into this
I want a baby
yeah it's called super snack time cuz
Epic Meal Time this is the craziest
thing is copyright which is a [ __ ]
yeah that's not seasoning so hold on
hold on it's copyrighted yeah so okay I
didn't expect this it's little
pepperonis yeah oh my god I swear to god
you could be a hundred percent honest if
you don't like it you could say it's not
it's not good you could you could say
that be everything want me to give you a
real review right now a hundred percent
100% be truthful ok well it's like honey
I'm thirsty
on first doesn't it taste like it shocks
me I'm not gonna lie it's like a mass of
meat that's like it looks like a potato
in the mirror like okay so visually it's
interesting but then I was like oh
that's kind of cool looks like pepperoni
yeah well they are it's pepperonis the
pepperonis I found that that jerky is
like sometimes dry or top right now at
that gas station [ __ ] I was like let's
changed the game let's bring in this
pizza flavor which our surprise pizza
doesn't exist this is gnarly that's
really cool this is like a little shot
of life I know isn't it crazy it's
actually pretty good right I've never
had anything like it no III swear I was
like I was shocked that a triangle bag
doesn't exist the that Pizza jerky
itself doesn't exist doesn't say stuff
like that yeah hundred percent you could
say that doesn't taste healthy yeah it's
it's it's high protein and low carb
somewhere I was telling you about Kido
mmm-hmm if you sat down and you had like
I'm still eating about if you had sick
by jealous if you had six slices of
bacon and three eggs for breakfast
you know people would be like Oh
cholesterol that's not really healthy
that's in line with a keto diet though
so if you want it this is the best way
to eat pizza if you're on Aikido because
your other option is making a
cauliflower pizza and then just [ __ ]
do I gotta say I mean I'm I'm heating it
I'm still eating it [ __ ] where are these
little nuggets here they look like
raisins glued to it raisins to our jerky
what is this what are the chunks so it's
like it's marinated and seasoned so
those look like Olaf those are like
delicious little like sauce pouches you
just like it's basically when you get a
chip and it has extra powder on it
you got lucky with that bite no here let
me read the packaging I I agree about
the texture it is not try what you don't
they have that I love trap I'm a jerky
guy I'm just gonna be frank with all you
right now so yeah I was gonna call it
Epic Meal Time Pete's in a bag but I
found out a human to calm down a huge
Food Company trademarked Epic Meal Time
in the food space in 2012
whoa and it wasn't you know was enough
did you combat that yeah but then you
just have to I have to just spend a lot
of money against it's like literally
like it's like a mega corny who was I
don't even want it that's how big
they're there's like five of their
products on this table right now so just
like that serious table oh no not that
what sneaky little [ __ ] actually
very sneaky big [ __ ] these were
like big [ __ ] mmm big ones you
know but actually it's like my first
lesson it's just like I was like America
yeah okay I'm gonna say I endorse it
it's great sweet it's fine
it's interesting I've never seen
anything like it before it's tasty oh
wow thank you where it's really cool
yeah we I it's it's so crazy because
I've pitched shows before like doing
this whole thing I've gone in and done
show pitches like I've been there like
waiting like in like you know the hall
of like this huge production company
being like I hope they like this show
when going in there doing the little
song-and-dance but it was just
interesting with this because I went to
Walmart to pitch it and that was just
different in itself oh so you did it
directly with Walmart yeah yeah I own
this it's not like a licensed one like
this is like this is how the hell you
make a food do they help you like how do
you make yes that's a jerky company that
makes the jerky and partnered with them
yeah and they make a jerky that's a
delish
Turkey and Walmart are you telling me
not to chew on the mic oh yeah
I'm sorry shredder I'm sorry you try
this you know I did I don't like eating
on the podcast but I did like well I'm a
[ __ ] I'm a big disgusting monster
that is why we look like we look thank
you for saying a proverbially so it
hurts less no and I look skinny you know
and that is why you're gonna die young
and I'm shredder gonna live on happily
you're not what is after you gonna gravy
grave I was saying that I was standing
up at YouTube and I was like [ __ ] y'all
for taking away the money yeah from all
the people anything they were like we
put up a blog post I know I was like
it's the same blog post if you have 75
subscribers or 7 million subscribers
yeah and they're Alejo can we appreciate
the irony of YouTube communicating
through blog posts yeah yeah all right
how you guys know what you're doing
y'all are in touch and then and then the
best part is and guys if you're watching
this and you get to go to the the
beautiful youtuber Illuminati secret
meeting which I do love YouTube also I
can't say I love YouTube but it's
important to criticize it as fun I was
watching a superwoman video and for like
seven minutes she was like YouTube's the
best love you to be so good with and she
went on about how great YouTube is then
she was like but and it's like she had
to do that before she criticized it so
six minutes of praising YouTube I had it
you know but like how [ __ ] dumb and
they bring us there and they're like
sorry we took all the money away for a
week without any one now can you go on
stage and dance right and dance to hype
up Ellen's YouTube channel and type up
James Corden's YouTube channel and now
you go to like YouTube trending you're
like oh great YouTube this is it
TV leftovers from last night Ellen
segment James Corden segment and it's
like I'm not bashing them although I
could bash Ellen for a long time I'm
just saying you look at this top ten
list of people and it's just gonna be
left over did you
Ellen for a long time oh my god tell me
about Ellen I'm licensed oh yeah watch
yeah I love that
I've watched Ellen I've started watching
Ellen I got on the treadmill recently
and I flip on Ellen just had a carrier
I'm just curious what's out there but
I've watched so I've watched a couple
episodes recently and I'd love to hear
all your all of your grievances well see
you guys actually touched upon it in one
of the videos something that I do bring
up and that was the girl it's like oh
look at you now you had to steal right
yeah
and for those that don't know she she
chief set up a ruse that would totally
encourage someone to steal an extra hat
or it's garbage
Ellen bar mitzva merchant good yeah it's
[ __ ] like four dollars not a
multi-billion yeah like over gives car
so don't get [ __ ] high and mighty
that someone took two hats yeah and she
so this what everyone could take one
thing and someone took two things and
she was like oh my sister at Ellen's
like oh you don't think we all have
sisters right everyone wouldn't we all
like to things like yeah like robbing
[ __ ] they almost if she said Nicole she
was a killer would go and hear that
woman to pieces for Ellen but I hope I
get a hat for this and we don't know if
like maybe her sister was supposed to
come she filled in for her sister made
her sister's sick we don't [ __ ] know
it'll tell you what I know I know that
Ellen Ellen's like a billionaire she you
know she's got her like slot machine
level she got her own slot machines and
yeah so she's the one for stealing a hat
when you got sluggishly Oh exactly and
so she's there and she's like oh look at
this road it's like oh wow Ellen you
know your billionaire and this girl's
like a peasant stealing two hats
let's shame her on TV what is the Ellen
slot-machine like when you lose does it
be like you took two hats it actually
says claim prizes or claim below both
prizes if you claim both prizes you get
nothing you web cam turns on and dreams
your family like pops up you line [ __ ]
like one not everyone's a billionaire
another one no Dan sent me something
another one was the the you know damn
Daniel yeah yes so damn Daniel okay
let's say you're the the damn Daniel
okay and I'm other guy that
says damn Daniel oh I got to some pics
of Ellen's oh man oh my god it's about
dancing
come on all right it's sorry to pull
that up and everybody you can open your
eyes again so let's say you're Daniel
yep and you just came to school in your
white vans mm-hmm now I'm here with my
$600 iPhone and I'm like damn Daniel
back at it again with the white you know
and I do that here like haha shut up and
then like damn Daniel everyday damn
Daniel damn Daniel right okay now if we
just black and white it you are the star
this wouldn't exist without the star
however this other kid you know he
bought this iPhone and he uses his data
and he is the guy saying to him Daniel
mm-hmm like that is his phrase you know
so I would say that they're equal in the
sense I would say the damn Daniel's the
artist the guy make he's the creator yes
and this is just the star yes the main
actor and this guy this guy's the
director the writer the producer and
disturb his it's his grade of work right
so let's just split it half half let's
say they're here okay they both go on
Ellen she gives that guy Daniel a
lifetime supply events he's already got
some slick new shoes you know but he now
he has a lifetime supply this guy the
friend that came with him a surfboard
that says I went on The Ellen Show was
she trying to be rude to him I think no
she wasn't trying to be rude to him what
she's trying to do in my opinion is
subtly place the seeds for a treacherous
backstabbing of these friends around
like in a year
oh these kids aren't anymore no way it's
now music oh yeah Daniel why don't you
just do it with your van so you have a
lifetime supply of and all I got is his
[ __ ] surfboard and he's like bro you
were always jealous of my wife back
that's why you filled me in the
beginning and then they bite each other
who knows but you know what I mean so
she's breaking up that's what I think
what a nasty wit how how is it hard her
face are crazy by the way Horus we're
done
whatever you know whatever I got scared
for a millisecond I saw you realize blah
[ __ ] I thought I thought about it I
thought kpop fan base you're okay I
thought you were a kpop fan every day I
fight for that for
oh you fought against the haters I fight
against a knife it against k-pop fans
wait I thought you were for Cape I am
they're so [ __ ] up so what is the key
about 25 plants I like I like I like
some kpop band some boy bands I find
them I find the mesmerizing the [ __ ]
fascinating and I think that they're the
pinnacle of money spent on pop music and
designer clothes and it's like they're
born and bred like they're like Spartans
except instead of kicking ass they're a
boyband right they're born from the
beginning and like they throw other
other kids like other Koreans in the
garbage that just don't have the look
they're like no in the trash in the
trash this one the pop singers do that
the there there if you thought the
Backstreet Boys were corporate shills
you have no idea what it's like in
whatever we loved them just like five
seconds ago I do love them but you just
call them corporate chills sometimes
when you talk about something like in a
way it sounds worse than it is in real
life you know like like this this in
this one this one video this one video
on YouTube this guy max describes Ric
Flair and he's like his skin is he's
like he looks like leather and he's this
weird old goober and he's so gross and
he's [ __ ] awesome and it's true
something he's never downed worse right
when there's explained but when you
really when you take it in yeah these
guys are nothing but you know they're
they're corporate shills okay but you
love them all they're there yeah they're
the best okay all right I get you I
understand so they they they're just
born and bred to be the best at this and
this is a very specific thing their
groom exactly to be in a boy band right
and their fans are very territorial hmm
and I like some fans bases and other fan
bases don't mix well and I went once and
I was like oh like I'm like I love BTS
haha my boys are so sick and I you know
this one's my favorite and then
literally people were like you [ __ ]
stupid jar mayonnaise and slit your
throat if you think you could be fan of
BTS they [ __ ] hate white people [ __ ]
you and I was like whoa there's really
intense they're like can't beat that
comedy racist [ __ ] yeah I actually i
screen shot so many people all different
pirates all different walks of life on
Twitter being like you [ __ ] scumbag
if you think you'll be fan of BTS I will
kill you I swear not like dude that's
crazy
though and they I like they kept sending
pictures of like a jars of mayonnaise
crying why why exam white and white
racist and they are like [ __ ] yes race
they're like another like they can't be
racist to white people you [ __ ] idiot
oh I was like what my people think that
I would look I'm like oh this is just
completely interesting on on so many
levels do that I kind of want to get
into k-pop now yeah yeah I got I got
like a list for you I got like a start I
like a list of please like I don't care
about the music I'm just interested in
the beef yeah and once you just go out
there I got just like like if you went
up right now and you're like huge I'm a
huge fan of jungkook like you'll see
your mentions are gonna change hue
jungkook
yeah Ju and GK oh okay you write that
and that sounds like that's a Korean pop
that sounds like a cowboy so weird it's
like a twist but it I bet if you see
it's a ghost they're gonna hear dude
they're I mean they're throwing
mayonnaise through the window right now
that's interesting yeah and I just I was
like oh yeah this is awesome
people were like I'm gonna [ __ ] kill
you crazy
I'll on the surface value it's like oh
this wholesome everyone's having fun and
seeing it and dancing and then
underneath it's just static don't ever
first she's so obviously what I did was
I was like well in that case I guess I'm
gonna be the fan club president so like
my bio has said fan club president for
like the last lexicon and Ryan I'm gonna
get messages being like yo mr. president
can I be in the BTS fan club and I'm
like hey just wanting to be in the club
get you access to the club alright and I
had some websites like throughout an
article being like Harley Morenstein
from Epic Meal Time is that there's the
BTS fan club president it was like
literally like written on this like
Korean website and I was just like oh
[ __ ] this is actually true and [ __ ]
weird it's not only was a weird that I
was wearing a kpop t-shirt with like a
young man's face on it but I was at Dave
and Buster's which is also weird I was
having a weird night and someone tapped
me on the shoulder and it was just like
young girl and I turn on shows are you
the BTS fan club president okay I swear
to God I unzipped my jacket where I had
a picture
I was like yeah and she went it is
usually staff and I get a picture no she
was a nice one at least so she
recognized you as the fan club leader
yeah well I was like damn serious brand
pivot working hopefully I got a couple
videos you wanna watch some videos yeah
I would love to
I've got did you hear about this count
dink EULA Chet the dog that's a dog yeah
yeah you guys you guys probably mostly
heard about this but I'll show you a
little clip I haven't actually had a
chance to talk about this I mean you
talk about it for a long time
this guy trained his girlfriend's pug
she's always she's always you know
doting over this pug saying I was the
cutest thing doting is that a word they
say that right whatever you guys know
what I mean I don't love the damn dog
yeah and the doc he taught the dog had a
Heil Hitler
this video just got demonetised
algorithms like a legume is like Heil
Hitler nope
so here's the video anyway he got locked
up in the UK so that's it happy so here
you can hear him saying it's the least
cute bang mm-hmm a Nazi yeah not glory
to Hitler all you know and the weirdest
thing is is like like he said that he
thinks it's not cute he thinks Nazis are
not cute so now he's talking about it
he's established his side of it yeah but
he doesn't think Nazis are cute so then
we are we're you know we're are
remembering the Nazis which is an
important thing right we should remember
that that's a [ __ ] up time that's true
we should remember it and if we remember
it through joking or whatever let's do
that but he started it off by saying
this you know and like actually member
the the I hate Jewish people PewDiePie
thing yes I always thought that that
entire video would be in completely
different and changed if you actually
right off the bat said it and I just
want to say I do not hate Jewish people
and then went through with it it means
something so different I've watched this
and I've gone over this before
alright but like it's really important
he paused there because he said
thought of the least yeah that context
easier put exactly put him where he is
yeah I [ __ ] it seems so logical to
anyone right everyone that we would talk
to seems to be on the same page I just
don't understand what is going so well
so let me basically I mean I thought it
was pretty funny I was giggling to
myself as I watch this
he says gasps the Jews and all that good
stuff and the dog piles Hitler's let me
find one because it takes me a minute to
train the dog that's funny
the pugs an obscene oh my god I'll say
the the accent is too spooky he got the
low speak German accent it gives me like
two real but well today is like okay so
in the UK apparently you're not allowed
to make Nazi jokes and they're actually
sentence his ass they're gonna throw him
in the slammer for a for a joke he's
gonna be in jail yeah how he's gonna be
every day he's gonna be in jail he's
like I think [ __ ] cannot believe that
I'm in jail and for every person that's
like what are you in for what are
something that they do that from the
movies yeah that is honestly I taught a
pug to salute Hitler and then privately
like this guy's a violent right and then
killed no and you killed who was you
kill yeah no I literally I thought that
my reaction is I don't know what the
laws are and I'm not English I don't
know what it's like to grow up there but
I'll say this it made me appreciate this
God blessed land of the free where free
speech is a tent-like we free speech is
an actual right that we have and that
would never ever happen here in America
and you and it's crazy to think that
even in UK the birth of civilization
someone can go to prison for something
so insane it makes you really appreciate
what it means to live in America I gotta
say this is what's interesting to me is
let's say I taught you how to kill
someone I just showed you how to kill
showed you how the fastest way to kill
someone with a knife and I showed you
and I trained you for a year on how to
kill someone
mmm-hmm and then you went and killed
someone right right
you did the crime yes but maybe I should
go to jail too maybe right but it was
you you should be punished mm-hmm I
don't like the idea of this guy going to
jail at all but if you really want a
black and white it that dogs are not see
how do we do with that Nazi dog yeah
what do we do with it right we got a dog
out there that will Heil Hitler that
watches Nazi propaganda the guys locked
up but he knows the difference does the
dog no no and what's messed up to me is
I hate to say it but like you follow
that logic you got to put that dog down
we have to put that dog down yeah well
it's not that I want to see that but if
you're gonna continue the crime you have
to guess that dog yeah exactly that
justice you really do I would like to
see that I guess that and I don't want
that but like you know what like if you
don't think that anything should happen
to that dog then you should have and
nothing shopping to that guy absolutely
you're moving you're moving
UK this is we started off talking about
killing dogs we'll make sure to touch
back on yeah I just was like when I saw
that I was like I don't know anything
about the UK I don't know about their
laws I thought that they had the same
freedoms we have but apparently not I
guess you can joke about that's who I
remember I went on a cruise way back in
the day like literally like 15 years ago
and I was hanging out with some kids
from America and there was a couple of
UK girls there and one of them at one
point was just like oh like if something
came up and I was going I'm Jewish News
like you're Jewish you're Jewish
he's Jewish you're Jewish like yeah and
like oh wow
I never met a Jew before and he went on
to talk about Jews and a lot of the
stuff he said was very racist it really
[ __ ] up and the UK girl was like if
you said that stuff in the UK you can
literally go to jail and in my head I
was like ah she's goofing around she
wasn't around so I don't think this is a
new thing right I think just that's how
serious it is I know in Germany and that
makes more sense to me that like if you
talk about Hitler or Nazi propaganda
you'll go to prison that makes sense to
me in Germany
they don't want they don't want to do
that whole thing again yeah that didn't
work out
yeah although in a weird way it did
because Germany is prospered they took
like a weird route there but they seem
to be doing well now hey not that bad
start a couple world wars like yeah we
made a couple mistakes but like it
worked out it's almost like you said a
couple false starts you find your
footing in the rim who might have
criticized their plan no would you go to
jail for that Joe great possibly
interview possibly in the UK I I don't
know maybe from that we're going again
but there's the possibility that you
could I try way too hard to be a funny
person to ever go to the you that's
right probably a guy that because that
that's the American spirit it's like if
I wanna say I'm gonna F a bunch of
frickin flips gasps a bunch of Jews that
it is a word that is a word guess know
if you said a word yeah F word that is a
word that's a derogatory word right I
swear
what's your point what are you saying oh
no I thought you were trying to say it -
like bypass a word but then you ended up
saying 100 counts oh here's my ultimate
point yeah okay there were UFOs on the
news like three months ago you guys see
those videos no full-on UFOs like f-16
fighter pilot Jets being like what the
[ __ ] it's a UFO look at that and it's
spinning and it's doing weird [ __ ] and
it's all that I swear to God I believe
aliens can invade earth they will be at
our doorsteps like it'll be like
Independence Day mothership small
waiting for that are you expecting that
it would be pretty cool
I hope I'm alive for it but I'm just
saying it could be there that's where we
could be at uh-huh and no one will talk
about it they're like oh my god this guy
this guy said something homophobic on
Twitter let's go get him boys and then
let's get mad fry or the mothership in
the area over New York yeah they could
be here what Deng kuelen said about the
Jews yeah exactly the black that is
borderline anti-semitic and I think we
should talk to him right now
yeah those aliens they could [ __ ]
wait yeah I just feel like that's where
we are on it's been about on earth now
did you follow the whole me being
accused of Transpo being transferred
that's what I was referencing earlier
yeah
those those very reaching I'm like I saw
that I'm like how far are we reaching
that yeah and I actually I saw that
girls post I was like oh she's just been
waiting too
use that meme format know that format
where you say that what you like she
just been waiting to do that and to just
she's like oh here's where I could jump
in on it so and she used it and then
it's like oh she's yeah but at first we
thought at first it was some sort of a
joke that I was missing like I mean I
don't know but then I realized it was
serious no I didn't see anything
like I don't know no it's insane table
we did a video we put up a video and
there was some weird jokes in the video
and I was like oh let's take that out
let's take that I edited this video like
so that had some weird stuff pulled out
and then I put it up and this girl on
Twitter was like you know I watch all
your stuff and this one really got to me
and I was like oh why I will take
criticism sometimes you know I was like
why is that she was like I just felt
like it was really offensive to vegans
and really super rude to vegans and now
I know that we made some jokes towards
vegans but we definitely didn't go
anywhere like they should [ __ ] die or
anything like that it was just ten on
ten hilarious joke and that was it and I
was like Oh Mike did I offend you she's
like no I'm not vegan I just felt that
it was very offensive and I was like
okay which part and she was like I'll
have to watch it again and I was like
this is the problem here because you're
not vegan but you feel like it's
offensive and you're gonna go back to
try and find out why you made me felt
it's just that everyone's got their
their their their sensors up on so
sensitive that like I I sometimes see
things
I'll watch something and I'll see it and
I'm like oh I bet people get offended
about that every day things happen I
look at that on my all people would get
offended about that right you know I
kind of like what you said I was
watching your Twitter video about the
doctor disrespect his Asian guy
character yeah and I like what you said
in a way where he was denying that it
was racist and you're like I like it
it's funny and it's rad it's racist yeah
it's like okay I kind of like that
acknowledgement of being like well first
of all I'm not acknowledging that what I
said is transphobic I don't want people
to know they're very different very
different later else but to be like okay
I chose to make a racist joke for the
sake of comedy but I think the most
important thing that nobody [ __ ]
considers of everyone who loves to get
angry all the time is that what really
matters is the intention yeah you're not
someone who
wishes harm or has bad intentions if you
make a racist joke that is harmless
because there's a you know well that's
it like I I'm like dude I like I I love
one of my favorite comics Anthony
Jeselnik says the most terrible things
ever most terrible things ever if he
ever worked to be like it's not that bad
it'd be kind of [ __ ] up that he says
that it's the fact that he's like oh I
know people know that I say [ __ ] up
things and I'm a huge fan of doctor
disrespect and like you know when he
does like like basically mimicking a
Chinese person's speaking mock Chinese
even though I think he's hilarious at it
and what do I know I'm a white Jew how
could I ever know if that is offensive
but if someone get another give that
disclaimer I don't know anything I'm a
white Jew I hate that problem too when I
was making that video about like my
response to the trans [ __ ] I was like I
I was thinking about saying something
like that but it's like I'm just a white
Jew yeah I don't know any you want to
preemptively you want to preemptively
like just stop those comments or can I
know but what I what I settled on is
this if if you went and you stubbed your
toe and you're like [ __ ] kills and I
was like let me see and I looked at it I
bet go it's fine you're not hurt
it does hurt you yeah I gotta trust that
it hurts you that's all
so if someone if someone asian is like
that's [ __ ] up yeah then I'll be like
you know pain is real maybe maybe it is
i-i'll just I'll believe you you know
cuz someone can go and like shake a jar
of pennies in my face now bike that's
[ __ ] up and I'm like no it's not like
well you know not it was knee high it
was a hack joke but now that you're
saying it's not [ __ ] up I want to
fight you you know cuz it is [ __ ] up
but like you just need to just know that
it's [ __ ] up and doing like the mock
asian thing is racist you can't you
can't yell ching chong at a Chinese man
and then say that it's not racist cuz
you know I think he was like you know my
girlfriend's dad's Hawaiian bro that's
cool something like that which is like
that doesn't cut it you know but I was
having a good time laughing at some
funny content that I thought was funny
but I'm a terrible person so I can laugh
at racist things I don't think you have
to be normal person except we need a
yeah you know a terrible person insane
anyway
that I'm terrible on that the most
sensitive person will find a million
reasons to get annoyed with me and
that's what but i'm i think i think
joking about sexuality and races and
yeah all that is important and I think
joking about the Holocaust is super
important also I think it's important
we're like joking is an art we'll
remember things by how we laughed at it
or whatever and if you like in that
scenario I wished that he would have
been like either a like huh my name is
dr. disrespect what the [ __ ] did you
think other than I would disrespect a
[ __ ] I'll disrespect the whole race and
you know whatever but then it got to
like a weird quasi play by the way I
don't follow the whole I didn't see his
response I just saw I like that what are
you explaining
yeah well cuz I felt like it could be
taken what I was said could be taken and
applied to lots of things well it's just
like recognizing what you're doing like
you know like like the PewDiePie's like
I I know it like the guy invited me to
sleep on the couch at his house if I
ever wanted to go and film with him you
know I don't think he hates Jewish
people he knows very well I'm Jewish you
know I don't think that's I never
thought that but the content yeah the
content the joke was anti-semitic in
definition but he is nowhere near an
anti-semite you know what I mean like in
my experience no that's not you know
what I mean so like it's it's like
people take the joke and and it's just
the comedy is at comedy is at risk yeah
okay I'm always Pro comedy that's right
I'm always like what I hated the most
was growing up is if like you know like
someone would make like a racist or
homophobic remark and I might say
something but I might make like an
anti-semitic one and then a Jewish
person would get offended and I'd like
no you're ruining the game because the
game is all or nothing and if you're
gonna get mad at one of them then you're
gonna ruin the whole concept of the game
and the like for me like I like pushing
buttons I like being extreme so always
default to saying something about Jewish
people because I can go to that far edge
and then be like oh it's our word the K
word you know I could say that it's fine
you know
and if someone else said I'd like oh as
long as it's funny let him do it if it's
not funny let's make fun of them for not
being funny but also just know when
you're being racist or know when you're
saying something homophobe
Bick or whatever and I thought your
tweet was however that even came is
being transphobic does not make sense to
me at all
that wasn't partly really frustrating me
was that like I didn't even know why I
was being such a reach it was just such
an intense reach that I thought it was
so goofy what am i I feel like it's just
that people are expecting at this point
that you shouldn't you should never be
offended by anything like it's fine to
be offended you can move on right it's a
normal healthy reaction that we live in
a society are supposed to feel you you
need to be able to talk and express
yourself you're gonna worry about every
little thing you may offend you can't
say anything anymore or if you get
offended I want that person to pay is
like that was this justice on the the
offensive aspects is weird by the way I
can only imagine how many people were
reporting our channel and trying to get
my Twitter banned and [ __ ] yeah because
that's it it's like a it's it's all
about retribution the thing that really
annoys me is like I'm I'm so pro trans
right and so liberal on social issues
and I feel like I'm an ally to them I'm
not a conservative Christian who thinks
that they're mentally ill or that
they're desecration of God or anything
like the [ __ ] that I hear that's really
awful I understand that growing up trans
is probably really it has to be
extremely difficult a lot of them are at
risk for suicide and depression and [ __ ]
like that and that you should call
people by the pronoun that they want in
the name that they want and I totally
understand respect that feel like I'm a
sensitive dude to their issues and it's
so it's like why are you trying to ruin
that alliance yeah I'm on your side dude
why are you segregating us people jump
people to jump the gun on pointing
fingers and what's weird about it is
like you know what I don't like is like
now if someone this week we're to Google
your name
it's just attached to something that
says like transphobic and that just
exists and it's there and then you know
obviously like some websites will
mention it or talk about it Ethan comes
recently accused of being transphobic
which is yes that's 100% true you were
recently accused of that and that makes
whether it's really baseless and
completely nonsense it's not gonna
yeah even like you know I was listening
the podcast with Shane like how terrible
that is the whole you know Shane Dawson
is dude that was insane that's [ __ ]
like that's 12 on 10 scary [ __ ] that
Twitter news that they featured that
exactly and how fast that gets out of
control like this is minor compared to
that yeah oh that's but that's insane
like and I I'm like you know that's
what's scary is like this day and age
like you know something could happen
someone someone could be accused of one
thing or whatever and then before you
know what you're in this box or there's
been where the company of that bin is
ten times worse than what you're even
falsely being accused of and that's
what's weird is you get thrown into
these bins we categorize it like oh yeah
first I think that Twitter should be
deeply ashamed of that whole Shane
Dawson thing that was just shocking I am
as borderline like Miss America you
should sue them I genuinely think that
what they did was borderline I can't
remember the [ __ ] word was it
defamation yeah what they did I know
they have some exemptions if they're
like journal journal but you have to
have there's some journalistic standards
yeah like you should use that power to
correct yourself
the next day never then and they kept it
up for a long time so [ __ ] up yeah it
just [ __ ] up but that was one thing
this it's like one of those under under
side risks of doing what we do is you
know you put your name out there and
like you said you you go on the mic and
you talk on the mic non-stop you're
gonna say some dumb [ __ ] or whatever
yeah or maybe you don't but people will
piece together some dumb [ __ ] or say you
can easily remove context from anything
there's this picture like this picture
that like I could see why someone would
think it was me like it almost could
show you the picture I'll follow if I
find it on my phone but it was just this
picture and it looks like a guy that
like could almost be me but he had like
a tattoo then I don't have a single time
what would you do it was just it was him
and then it was this girl that looks
like it could be another another
youtuber like really if you wanted it to
be and their faces were blurred hmm but
like there were like naked together and
like it looks like it could be me and
another youtuber and I just remember it
like the week that it went on Twitter
like in 2014 people were tweeting it
like crazy and like Mike
girlfriend at the time was just like
look is this you and I was like yo I'm
like look at my shoulder I'm sure this
is like my girlfriend were in the same
apartment look look at my shoulder I
have no hair this guy's got hair all
over and surely you're lucky and I'm
like I am lucky and it's like this is
you but the people that are looking at
this picture they don't have me showing
them my shoulder they don't know me as
well there's like damn damn dog look at
you - you did this and it's like not a
thing that happened you know that's
great but yeah it's just wild just what
it is and it's funny cause like I'm
sitting here like sharing this with you
guys right now and like there's still an
element of me male just even randomly
sharing there wasn't even anything bad
to it there's nothing bad to it it's
like okay yeah we [ __ ] each other even
let's just say that is what happened
when it's not but like I'm still sharing
and it is somewhat an innocent enough
thing and I'm casually sharing and like
I know it's not but there's still an
element of like you know you get this
aspect of like I don't know if I should
believe this was it that they thought
that you that you [ __ ] I didn't want
to I don't want to say because I feel
like it's like a thing and then it's
like kind of like a thing but it's
definitely not someone that would ever
[ __ ] me someone that I know well enough
and I would tell you that they would
never they would never mess exactly so
if they enough every time I got you you
have the best you've got all the Jews
all the stories you were there from day
one I know a lot of it you would never
say on camera
every time I see it this guy he's
telling me [ __ ] that's blowing my mind
[ __ ]
is there any stories you can tell on
camera that is just like the greatest
craziest YouTube [ __ ] it's a good one I
could tell on camera the best [ __ ] you
guys I'm telling you get this guy off
camera oh boy you're on it's too bad
like 90% of them are like incriminating
- yeah Tom berry I mean every moment was
extremely incriminating to all of our
favorite youtubers yeah there was I
remember there was a point like where
like it was like you know Toby Turner of
course
Toby Turner was like the Great Gatsby of
YouTube at one point where he had
parties every single weekend at his
house and they were like extravagant
parties like Thursday Friday Saturday
and I just remember going to those
parties and be like something bad is
gonna happen here something bad will
happen there's just too many youtubers
too many people getting [ __ ] up I just
feel like something bad will happen and
I remember I used to go there like all
the time and like you know I had some
somebody some guys that were on Epic
Meal Time then and they were just like
oh man
maybe we should stop coming to getting
[ __ ] up then I remember the last time
I went it was like the last straw of
we're like okay let's go was we went in
the backyard and like in the hot tub was
like someone that I recognized from like
fine brothers like teens react mm-hmm
and this is like a party there's like
drugs going around and drinking going
around we walking and I look in the back
I'm like yo I'm like that's one of the
kids from teams we act like we leave now
let's go that was the last time I was
there but anyone who's ever been at a
tobyturner party who's ever gone to any
of those they've been [ __ ] up they
know they got [ __ ] up
everyone's been [ __ ] up at those
parties everyone like every youtuber if
they've ever been like oh I remember the
I was at a Toby Turner party and this
they were on what they were on ecstasy
probably yeah everyone those were the
days on those were the do tube days
right you know what it was funny is like
it my experience on YouTube going
through so many phases that I have been
I can recognize enough that sometimes
someone will say to me like you know if
I talk to one of the guys who used to be
on Epic Meal Time they're like man then
whatever man those were the days and
then a part of me thinks I'm like these
are the days and I know that's like a
weird thing to say but like we are still
in the days and I know that like there
were times where I'm like oh those were
the days but like these are the days to
in a weird way like I had like the days
where I remember that when like Epic
Meal Time was like fastest growing
number one channel on YouTube it was
like you know like 10 million views a
week and we were like going like up like
25,000 subscribers or a week and that
was a lot more those yeah yeah those
were the godly numbers yeah there was it
was messed up those were the days and it
was like Food Network was like had a
show where they had a guy that looked
exactly like me but it was just like
doing like we're doing outrageous foods
it was like over Aegis meal fibers all
right and like you know huge
corporations are trademarking our brand
I'd like to accept those were the days
but then after that you know we moved to
LA and living in LA like those were the
days and then we got to work with like
some people like Arnold Schwarzenegger
or Seth Rogen James Franco and I'm like
those were the days
but like then there's an aspect of it
where I said about like I think about
the times where we've met where I met
you guys the YouTube thing or something
like coming here and I'm like these are
the days where to pizza and a bag for me
is like these are the days there are
like the days are like there's just so
many you know there's just like it's all
the days like it'll all be one when you
look back in 20 years from now it'll all
be the days you know like the the the
Joey salads and like you know the
lawsuit and the podcast everything will
be like into the days yeah that's all I
think that's healthy I think that's a
that's a good outlook for anyone who's
listening because I think people have a
tendency to be like always looking back
yeah the truth is about the days too I
mean you'll talk about this all the time
like we idealized the time we were in
Santa Cruz and we're like man those were
the days back then like we were broke
now we even sometimes talk like that
about the times in Israel right all the
times in New York but you remember sighs
it and you're like those were the days
but when you actually like meditate and
think back you were miserable back then
there were a lot of complaining for like
man YouTube's so [ __ ] up these days I
was like dude YouTube has always been
[ __ ] up yeah do you think it's [ __ ]
up now people used to complain and be
like why is there 15 Taylor Swift parody
music videos on the front page every day
why doesn't my content pause and like
there was always something like that
there was always an element like you
know people are like oh I heard this
youtubers like not even that nice to
everyone it's like people said that
about like raywilliamjohnson back in the
day I thirst he hates me whoo hey
William yeah I bet well I don't know why
I've never caught though I all I don't
I'm I'm he's before my time on YouTube I
didn't really watch his colony is I know
about its lawsuit case because he was
our predecessor he lost his case I
studied a little bit in preparation for
our case and why
he lost and what you know why did that
happen but I he's a real interesting guy
I appreciate what he's accomplished and
I was like hey you should come on the
podcast you know I love to be a really
interesting conversation because we have
a lot in common Ally the guy does he
watch his videos that's kind of what we
do we both been a lawsuit about fair use
so somebody I tweeted at him he didn't
respond but I got a lot of attention
somebody showed me a screenshot they've
been following each other for a long
time for some reason they know each
other I guess and he's like hey you
should go on the h3 podcast I heard that
he wanted to have you on there and he
blocked him straight-up blocked him did
I mean what's that about so I listened I
met I was kind of like I met him I met
him a few times in Jefferson and he
hangs out with Jeff Dunham by the way
it's interesting you know what cuz like
you know what like I I come from a place
where it's like this if you if you make
content you put yourself out there then
you are open game for discussion we can
talk about you we can that's just how it
is I think there's there's there's a
fine line to that like I I'm for you
know the content you guys make I'm about
that I find it weird like sometimes when
a creator will like you know talk about
like an 11 year old girls Instagram feed
you know like rice gum content is weird
- I agree and there's a difference but
when someone like gray he's like you
know he's a real person I've met him
before he's been nice to me I do know
that he doesn't like being the topic of
conversation so I know even in this
scenario I from what I remembered of him
I haven't hung out with him in years is
he wouldn't like that I'm even
discussing right now about him but
there's an element of when you become
the top there's an element we might
never really grasp unless you've been
there yourself like I remember when
jenna Marbles was blowing up and that
sky rocketing like how that affected her
in my encounters with her personally I
saw Logan Paul when he was on vine and
then I saw him when he was on YouTube
before he popped and then I saw him when
he was skyrocketing and there was
something similar there there's a
similar what is
this detachment to an extent of like
relationships and whatever and there's
this element of any any person that you
can think of or speak to were people
that would message you there's an
element in this position where it's like
what do they want from me
what is that person why I have mean I
definitely the element of that so if
you're number one yeah and then you've
been number one then you have that
feeling with everybody yeah sure so you
know like Logan had adore I've noticed I
thought maybe Jenna may have have it but
but Ray had a strong aspect of that that
you know I'm sure he was one of the
people that were there way beginning way
early on and maybe there was that
element of like what does this person
want from me from him you just him and
Jamie on the podcast yeah but but like I
did but why are you trying to you trying
to put me on blast but rose yeah yeah so
yes this and this is an important one to
this scenario is I went out and I and I
tend to be someone who connects with
everyone I literally I met like one
person on YouTube that I didn't like
literally everyone else like I like and
I went out once and it was a scenario
where I I went to this club and Ray was
gonna be there and Sam pepper gave me a
lift so it was just like an interesting
night your ass no this was pre ass
touching and so I got there with Sam and
I was at wallbrook grace ray was there
yeah and he this is the perfect
encounter that sums him up in a way Sam
went up to him was like oh my god I'm a
huge fan
I made YouTube because of you I can't
believe it like it's just you made me
want to be a youtuber hmm Narae said to
him I'm not a youtuber and then Sam said
raywilliamjohnson and he was like yep
and he was like yeah you're a youtuber I
used to watch equals three I loved it
like you made me want to do this and
like you know and I literally like I
loved your channel he goes cool but I'm
not a youtuber I think as well you were
a youtuber he was like I was never a
youtuber and he was like mad and he kind
of stepped away and Sam was like to me
like I'm getting mad like I'm getting
mad at him why is he saying he's not a
youtuber right and I was like well let's
be let's be honest it's pretty lame
but we all are he totally is yeah yeah
we're all youtubers you know but like
saying you're youtuber maybe is an
element that you don't want like I knew
that he you know he's he's a musician
he's a writer he had directed content
that did not go on YouTube so if you
just say you're a youtuber maybe he felt
like that was limiting what he's done or
whatever but he that encounter himself
is I don't know anyone else that would
have had 9 million subscribers where
eight point nine nine nine nine nine of
them would refer to them him as a
YouTube and one of them would refer to
him as their son you know and everyone
else would be like a youtuber so well
also that when if when an impressionable
fan comes up to him is just being nice
and looking for a little yeah well who's
also now in his own right he was
successful at that when he was probably
I remember yam was a big deal yeah so it
was like that in itself it was just
weird and I'm in the middle and that
just right there I mean I guess to an
extent can give you a hint at you know
huh what the mind frame you know so it
might not be that he hates you but it is
interesting that he went and blocked
that purse just [ __ ] bro but that comes
from a really sour talks place that's
not a help happy man who's blocking
people just watch you know I I found it
I interested like you know like maker
studios had like a weird dynamic back in
the day like I used to go there and it
was very strange because it's like you
have all these employees that want to be
youtubers and want to create channels
but they're now until they get their
break they're working for other channels
and that person's coming is like edited
better breath inches you know and it's
like you are you're working for this
guy's channel but you want to be
spending time on your own channel yeah
but you're trying to work your way
you're trying to make something happen
you're trying to figure it out so I
think maker just had a very strange
dynamic but I remember people used to
bash ray like I'd go to VidCon and be
like VidCon Ray's not even at VidCon
thinks he's too good for VidCon
and my only thought process is maybe
he's just really uncomfortable or
unhappy or you know like I don't know
when when I started doing YouTube when I
went to the first VidCon I was shocked
at how strange every creator was hmm I
left my bag yo you oh my god I love your
shouldn't he like to say I was like oh
it must have taken us
particularly be like I am gonna go on
this site YouTube which doesn't even
make money yet
yeah and I'm just gonna for fun talk to
no one and say like me follow me
subscribe to me and I'm gonna upload it
every day and I'm not even like getting
paid for it or anything I'm just doing
it because this is who I am and I just
noticed that I'm like well those people
are different people from myself now
it's different now it's like being a
youtuber so cool in this day and age you
know like someone like when like I was
telling Tim to leggett I was like bro
when you uploaded your first video to
YouTube Jake Paul was six yeah like he
was six years old right so he grew up at
a time where it's like yeah what YouTube
it's actually cool to be a youtuber bro
alright
like Rey grew up at a time where it was
not cool in fact it was uncool in fact
you were just using it as a milestone
stepping-stone to get to other stuff to
be respected in auditions you know I
used to talk to me he said he used to
wash dishes in his videos to seem
relatable with the audience he never
wanted to say that he had an Escalade at
the time he didn't want to talk about
his fancy car or his fancy lifestyle
because he thought that would be weird
for the audience where I remember when
we came onto the scene we were like oh
let's pretend like were rappers well
we're gonna pretend we have money before
we had money like we said YouTube money
before we ever got our first paycheck we
were just like let's just be like we got
a million dollars doing good good you
know but it was just too counterculture
what was happening then but he came at a
time where it was like uncool to be a
youtuber you know so maybe he is just
not a happy guy I really I don't know I
don't anything about the guy he's
interesting did and I'd love to sit down
oh I think it would be and I'm sure
someone's gonna be like gray they spoke
about you at this moment and check this
out rage he's in this pod right here if
you block me if you don't want to come
on huh and if you do want to come on
follow me those are your two options
yeah you can't do it nothing yeah he is
friends with Jeff Dunham I've noticed
that he's friends with Jeff Dunham who
is my personal friends there's they may
be together they're friends they're like
I could work because they're cut from
the same block of uh I don't think he
would work with someone that he doesn't
like personally I like I think if he's
working with someone
likes them personally I think if he's
working with someone he's bringing them
into like his you know I think it is
what you just said connected with me I
think he's like doesn't even want to
associate with this [ __ ] that's going on
here yes cuz he's a big [ __ ] deal he
makes collabs with Jeff Dunham are the
best pass the most powerful comedian
that's ever lived who puts puppets on
his hand and tells racist jokes through
the puppet so he's not accountable he's
friends with the great and wonderful
Jeff Dunham and he'll be goddamn become
waste his time with me he prefers to
spend his time with peanut he prefers to
spend its time with the talking jalapeno
peppers it sounds like over-the-top
Mexican so I'm way I'm way way way below
his level let me ask you this yeah we oh
we didn't do the giant babe bring up the
giant babe for Christ's sake and so
important we totally forgot yeah all
right you got to hit this thing it's
customary that uh this is like
ceremonial yeah usually good in the
beginning but we forgot so hit this hit
this monster would you now it's not a
competition between the guests at all
it's been sanitized so don't worry about
that it's been spit shined by Dan is
there chronic in this there's no chronic
it's just vape juice now is Shetty okay
I think he's just yeah he's all right
now it's not a competition but there
there's a friendly exchange between
people to see who can rip the fattest
vape cloud so don't worry about it you
know but like let me warn you let me
give you some advice if you rip it too
hard you coffin when you cough the smoke
disappears so you have to find a balance
of ripping it really hard and not too
hard so the buttons right there and you
just suck you're gonna love it
yep yeah that's where you suck from yeah
I every time yeah all right
Godspeed I can't wait
I would go all around it yeah for max
suction you're very you're very is
you're very self-aware about holding
that little phallic tube wrapping your
mouth going yeah don't worry man just
put your mouth around that little tube
and suck it here we go ladies and
gentlemen staff a trip he's very tender
very dainty you can take another good at
it yeah you know you that was impressive
cuz you coughed but you also still got a
pretty fat rib it was no it wasn't that
big but you caught if you didn't cough
it was gonna be a lot really big yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's a bat cloud it's
uh donut I don't know so thank you for
doing that by the way how was good did
it hurt the first rip yeah a little bit
oh no it's so closed it out and it's
like it went yeah sometimes when it's
not been serviced I don't know why just
told me it was clean there everything is
clean the tube is clean not been used
but sometimes I don't know why trips so
harsh
it's like battery acid and like so you
know it's so funny vape scary the worst
like like if you have a vape you suck
online automatically did you know this
let me explain let me clean I have an
account on Instagram mm-hmm it's
literally a toy account
it's my side passioned fun project I
have little dolls
I swear 12-inch dolls like Star Wars
force diagram it's called young toy boy
why you ng to a boy yeah so I put this
up and sometimes I'll tell people how I
made a picture
like I'll be like oh here's what I did
like and I'll be like the background is
cardboard I mean we'll shot I'm using
the hot toys r a picture or a sideshow
Boba Fett and the alien queen and then
I'll say like and then III use like a
blue light and I'll say I took my vape
which I literally bought the vape for
this and then I bought the vape to their
atmosphere to blow it yeah into the
picture so there's smoke in the picture
this is why I bought the vape and I'll
tell people I'll put the picture up and
I'm like yeah check it out into the
sideshow Boba Fett I put some cardboard
in the back there and I blew my vape for
the smoke effect mm-hm and then all the
comments are like you have a vape oh my
god you [ __ ] loser or kill yourself
there's no [ __ ] you're so garbage Wow
made more douche bag jeez and I'm like
yo I literally just I'd literally just
took a picture of dolls there's a lot of
people these are lighting to kill you
these are pictures of malls
I took a picture of dolls and I sent
them up with fake plants and everything
like that and I took the picture and
you're gonna comment me for the vape a
more Pro like yeah exactly
I'm like a grown man lying on my tummy
on the streets taking a picture of toys
yeah this is pretty much I'll be like oh
man use your vape Wow
[ __ ] you suck bro you suck and I'm
like but how did that outshine the fact
the fact like a grown man payment yeah
we got playing with all there's not
really crazy really cool actually yeah
do you ever feel discriminated against
because our producer Dan Azov is a big
actual vapor dan do you ever feel
discriminated against for vaping no no I
mean I see the hate online but not in
real life not in real life
oh my god they're probably talking [ __ ]
behind my back but a hundred percent
they are when you leave everyone's like
that vaping Wow by the way I didn't want
to say in front of him but Dan is a
[ __ ] babe we always ask their guests at
the bottom of the show if you have any
and it's okay if you don't have them
okay paranormal extraterrestrial or
unexplainable stories that have ever
happened to you ghost stories yeah you
okay god bless you what do you got for
me so I I was dating this girl not my ex
my ex but the other ex before
epicMealTime ever happened in my
basement mmm
and I always felt like weird vibes in my
basement like I'd wake up sometimes and
I felt like I couldn't breathe mmm you
know and I'm not someone who's like
there's ghosts but I am someone like
maybe there's ghosts you know I'm like
you know I'm very like anything is
possible to exist or not exist who knows
it was her in trouble then grab him let
him out of the room and so what happened
was I there's this ghost in in in
history or in different cultures that
sits on your chest I've heard yeah and
you could wake up maybe like or in your
dream you can breathe or you're kind of
awake and you know you're napping but
you can't breathe and it's like it's
like hard to breathe mmm and it's like
there's this just I I experienced and I
remember experiencing it in googling and
then finding that's in culture there's
just like this ghost that sits on your
chest whatever you know it's a thing
whatever I had these weird experiences
and then I remember being in bed with my
girlfriend at the time and it felt like
we're both in bed and I wake up it's
like 4:00 a.m. and it's black in the
moments all the lights are off and I
felt like someone was at the edge of the
bed kind of like pushing down on the bed
and it felt like the bed was moving a
bit and I felt that and my face was up
against the wall so I like put my finger
on the wall to see if my finger was
moving or if I was just imagining this
bounce
hmm and I felt my finger like going on
the wall so I was like it feels like
someone's here hmm
and so I roll over this way so I'm
facing her now but you know I don't know
if she's facing me or what if she's
sleeping whatever and I rolled over and
she just goes Harley Harley
I wasn't quiet she goes there's someone
here and I look at the foot of the bed
and it's everything's black but at the
foot of the bed it's extra black like
really dark like ultimate darkness so
there's just like two things you could
do here I could scream at the top of my
lungs
or I could fight I kind of did a mix of
both I like stood up and I was like and
like fell through whatever was there or
wasn't there and my light is behind it
so when I fell through it I hit my light
and my light turns on and she's got
tears all over her face she's like there
was a ghost here for like 20 minutes I
swear he was there don't freak out and I
totally thought there was I was like oh
don't worry I wasn't gonna be like oh my
god I felt it too so I was like aw don't
worry you stupid idiot you thought there
was a ghost here you must feel foolish
like we'll just keep the TV on if it
makes you feel better you know I'm not
putting the TV on and keeping the light
on and everything I'm like it was a
weird encounter fast-forward a week from
then I wake up in the middle of the
night and I'm just trenched in sweat
like I'm sweating I'm drenched and I'm
like full-on like like having rage sex
and I like what when you wake up I wake
up but I'm doing I'm like covered in
sweat and I was like what during a
sexual act when you I'm having sex okay
I'm having sex right now and I'm like
what is I like pull out and I'm like oh
my gosh I'm like what's going on she's
like what are you doing I was like what
happened here she was like I don't know
you just you just got really one-track
minded about it and he wanted to do it
and I was like I did this again like it
wasn't me and she was like no it was you
and I'm like no I think that was the
ghost from the other week that did this
and she was like what are you talking I
was just like I don't know I'm sweating
and I don't remember starting this and
that's not when do I ever do this and I
don't want to do this and I think I
think he's [ __ ] with us or he [ __ ]
you or whoever that is or whoever the
ghost was that I didn't do this look
look at me I'm soft now I don't even
want to be here I didn't want this I
waited you were actually having sex with
your girlfriend I was fully having sex I
woke up and I was in the middle of sex
and then all of a sudden you were like
wait I was at whoa I'm awake now who did
that she's like you're being weird why
don't you just bang this one out let's
get back to bed I was like no tell me
how did we get to this place
crazy but she was like you did this
she's like you woke me up you didn't say
anything you were just really one-track
minded about
Oh oh my god that's ever happened yeah
those are the only scenarios that that
happened I I her and I didn't stay
together much longer anyways and I
didn't stay in the house much longer
anyways so I don't know if it was her or
the house but those were the encounters
that time that a ghost [ __ ] my
girlfriend Oh No yeah and usually a dick
yes use my pathetic dick as a mere
vessel for this of all the Dixon of all
the disappointing David in the world
mine was selecting this ghost dick
alright the be exercise I have an honor
in a way spooky and and and and fighter
I jerked off with holy water to exorcise
the demon visa following that's right
the Pope ribs website yeah that's great
thanks for sharing that Amy told me to
can I say can I say that I've been I've
had experiences it's a type of
sleepwalking I happen for a period of
like a year or two where same thing
would happen to us where I would wake up
having mid like mid sex like I would
wake her up and initiate it and then
come to and not remember it at all I was
waiting to see if you'd bring it up but
yeah it was like how much do you want
Amelia yourself I'll let you do it no I
don't want talking about it's just that
weird then did you feel that I that
ghosty was even better than you Frankie
wasn't self-conscious like oh yeah like
after that you're like all you thinking
about ghosts oh yeah but you are nobody
was just like he's awake like himself
you're not talking to me and everything
and then just wake up all of a sudden
like what's happening it's a weird one
is it the house you think it happened in
Israel only mm-hm
I don't know we move I know I guess
there's old enough to be pretty on there
so make up [ __ ] take it over my dick
dick gets taken over
I find I find some places to be more
haunted than others and every time I go
to Hollywood I walk into a hotel in this
place so [ __ ] haunted there's so many
disappointed ghosts that died here they
just wanted so much more than they got
right and now they're bound to this room
they'll have I'm trying to sleep
oh no you know I have an audition
tomorrow and this is this ghost a man
yeah this goes to just pissed about this
they're gonna curse your audition I've
been I've been cursed so many times and
in Hollywood hotels I just feel like
every single one is like every time I go
into a room and Hollywood I'm like
someone died here sad it's like every
single room in all the way right I'm
like someone had a terrible death in
here that's probably true we were we got
a room in Vegas and there was blood on
the ceiling on the ceiling on the
ceiling and I came out oh my oh my
brother I was like Darrin like look at
his but he went like this went ass blood
oh who said that bad it was that's blood
blood he just for him he assumed that
has blood would get on the ceiling first
than any other blood I'm trying to
imagine a scenario where that happens
like that he shoots like that he shoots
a bloody diarrhea on the roof every
scenario I share is terrible ass blood
yeah a split that he came in he was like
oh my god ass blood no it's cool san
aspie I think it must be all right well
I'll leave you guys with that ass blood
and go stick yeah and what about you and
everyone part of the us and let's not
forget it in the mirror this stuff's
great
I urge you all to give it a shot because
it's it's interesting and I guarantee
you've never had anything like it and
it's really good I love you found a
flavor raises you think you're putting
it back in the bag I want that one will
touch the ground or something I would
have totally popped that raisin flavor
that that's some for the boys flavor
raisin oh you did yeah there's much for
the boys over there cool some Buffalo
one and pepperoni cool and well
congratulations that's really exciting
to the cool product that does really
great yeah I hope so I mean I'm hoping
Americans do what I want them to do and
that's go to Walmart by your feet the
bag nothing face it it's low-carb also
though low-carb if you wanted that you
know if you wanted that it's low-carb
right
that's it that's all we got thanks
everybody for watching
appreciate you god bless you love ya
what else what are we doing next week
we don't know I've exciting announcement
next week we have no guess but the week
after ninja is joining three yeah wow
that's gonna be a big one ninja is on
Monday the next I think we didn't
finalize the date but I think it's gonna
be on the 23rd so that'll be cool
well get hyped which get hype yeah
anyway 500k a month I think he makes
even more that's just that article I
know that was like alkylating the
numbers and then I was like I don't know
where his sub-account got but it was
some more like eight hundred thousand
dollars a month just from subs that's
stupid it's insane god bless him good
I'm happy that this world exists I'm so
happy that that guy was able to carve
out he's fired
alright good guys by the way guys he
smells really good we better at home
wondering if I the dog yeah we walk
alright enough
[Music]
what's a goodbye see you guys next time
love you
[Music]